and Kerry Wood
never give up never give up no matter
what they say and believe me you find a
way around things no matter how how long
it takes everybody has told me jack get
away drop get rid of the film sell it
will make another one I said what do you
mean let's analyze those two statements
get rid of the film and make another one
now that's easy to say but you know get
rid of the film as they take the film
cans leave them on the street corner
that's it that's how you get rid of and
then go make another movie so who's
going to invest in you in the private
sector when you haven't returned the
investment to the first school and in
forgotten heroes I have a lot of family
friends and high school buddies so if I
can't pay them back how am I going to
pay a total stranger a venture
capitalist aura or an entrepreneur am I
going to pay them back so that's that
that's the devil and fight so I've stuck
by this project too because I believe in
it just the response i'm getting from
vietnam veterans around the country it's
just been absolutely phenomenal so